James what are the first five things you
do when you arrive on set mm-hmm
first five things I don't think anyone
has asked me that question before the
first thing that I like to do is see the
actors if they are on set because I want
to talk to the actors about what's going
on for the day if I've done my job as a
director the crew should already know
they should know what the shots are
going to be because I've already made
the list they should know what the
blocking is because we probably already
talked about advance in pre-production
so I'm going to talk to the actors first
make sure that we're on the same page
creatively make sure they understand
what the dramatic arc is for the day and
where we are in that dramatic arc so for
example say we're shooting a film half
scene halfway through the film but it's
only the first week of filming what
point does the actor need to be at
emotionally so that way we can work with
them later on and earlier in the
narrative story that's very important so
I like to talk to actors about that
second thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to go talk to my DP and the crew
respectively I need to make sure that
the blocking that we talked about that
the shots that we talked about that the
set all of those things are in order so
that way whatever we might have
discussed in pre-production is being in
fact executed for production third thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to go to
video village and see how everything is
established is my iPad there I work with
my iPad for the screenplay and various
things like that and kind of see if
everything is set up for me to be
comfortable do I have water do I have
coffee do I have a banana things that
are going to enable me to sit there and
really watch it as I'm going back and
forth between the actors and video
fourth thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to go visit the DI T because I
want to see what we filmed previously
and how it's coming out one of the
things I deploy in my process there's a
guy work with that has a van that goes
anywhere you go if you're filming on
location and deploys all of the footage
to a wireless iPad network so you can
see what you've shot in previous days
and see if it's matching so if I need to
match something in the scene we're about
to shoot I might want to see okay well
where did we exit in this previous scene
and where are we going to come in to in
this one that enables me to remember
things visually that I may not
member just trusting my head and then
finally I'm going to sit down with the
producer and chat about how things have
been going and see how we are for
scheduling see how we are for timing and
even for budget you know what kind of
things that we have spent money on what
kinds of things are we going to need to
spend money on in the future days ahead
and do we need to make a cuts or
revisions or changes because if I find
out that there's a piece of equipment or
a lens or whatever it is that I need for
a future day and for various reasons the
budget has changed or we can't get that
because of a scheduling issue or
whatever it is I need to modify that in
advance so it's not an issue that we
have to deal with on the day of and
those are the five things I would do
you